richard branson hará historia al
convertirse en el primer multimillonario
en viajar al espacio a bordo de una
aeronave que él mismo ha financiado a
través de su compañía virgin galactic
con esta hazaña el británico se situará
a la cabeza de la carrera por los viajes
turísticos a la extra a la estratosfera
algo que también están siguiendo muy de
cerca el lo más que el fundador de tesla
y jeff bezos de amazon de hecho este
último había anunciado que viajaría al
espacio el próximo 20 de julio pero
aunque branson ha dicho que esto no es
una carrera por llegar el primero lo
cierto es que su compañía movió ficha
rápidamente para avanzar el viaje del
magnate y así convertirse en el primero
de ellos en realizar una experiencia de
este tipo la salida se ha un
poco pero se espera que en unas o dos
horas y media el viaje y unity despegue
desde el aeropuerto espacial space port
en la ciudad de truth or consequences
aquí en nuevo méxico unas instalaciones
de última generación situadas en medio
del desierto que también fueron
financiadas por el magnate en por el
magnate del reino unido- branson ha
admitido que siempre ha soñado con ir al
espacio y fue por eso que en 2004 hace
17 años fundó virgin galactic
ha dicho que ese sueño se va a hacer
realidad está previsto que la
experiencia dura aproximadamente unos 90
minutos en el espacio donde esté
triplicar a la velocidad del sonido a
unos tres mil setecientos kilómetros por
hora y a una altura de 80 kilómetros no
lo hará solo también le acompañan en
tres de sus compañeros de trabajo en
virgin galactic y que en los últimos
meses han estado trabajando en este
proyecto que de alguna manera abre las
puertas al turismo espacial un negocio
que el propio branson quiere impulsar a
partir del próximo año tiene un costo de
250 mil dólares y según la compañía unas
distintas personas ya están en la lista
de espera para formar parte de este
viaje